welcome to this video playing I'll
champion one yep something else there
let's go forward Sicilian some more
variety what character maybe play the
classical which is basically something
that I have to yeah invent now the over
/ the ball in the game I have no idea
really just a very vague idea what
theoretical lines might be yeah I think
this is something Queen here hmm so
you're saying that I cannot grab the
pawn down only for why not why not I
think this is actually really a
theoretical line so there should be a
reason it's not a blunder 94 93 Knight
c3 is there's something there don't see
it I cannot check this
yeah there must be a reason and really
must be a reason but I don't see it why
is he just playing for development I
Queen f3 maybe maybe Queen f3 I Queenie
f3 is the thing ok ok me took me a long
long long time kareena three that take
by go maybe 95 ok yeah anyway ok I'm
happy f3 is not a move that doesn't help
him so much usually the combination of
f3 and Bishop c4 this kind of thing in
the Sicilian doesn't doesn't help so
much at least against I mean ok it's
typical for the dragon but in this kind
of setup it's normally not very
effective so I can take now or not so
this and be five maybe why the check on
the kingside doesn't look very very
quick always then 95 noise check so I
can do that
my idea is to harass the bishop with the
the later a5 a4 if i go to c7 he might
just take the pawn mmm it's it's risky
to take it but you might still do it
maybe to be five actually that's not so
bad yeah let's go to be five and shoot
for a5 a4 that way yeah here we go mmm
yeah Bishop c6 doesn't look very
convincing i wonder if i can just play
Knight h5 no I think I can I mean a five
is also threatening a foursome mmm I can
also go to e8 by the way something that
I should have seen a lot earlier okay
see form yeah to take or not to take
that's the question that actually looks
quite good I mean I'm threatening a 4
and b3
if to watch the time yeah okay up to
eight down to eight so let's let's go
forward oh yeah so this is how he avoids
that the immediate be three let's go
here I can get the night to e6 actually
that's not so bad and I was thinking if
five here maybe if I've 96
yeah let's do that and let's see if we
can get some some pressure here I cannot
open up the queenside at the moment
that's a bit of a shame hmm it feels a
bit slow
it feels a bit slow really
k mama taking see form very slow yeah
that was how I must've made some kind of
mistake that I will it look like I'm
much quicker on the queenside maybe I
have to see for I should have taken
maybe I should have taken
I mean I'm not sure that I'm really I
know a huge trouble here but it feels
like something went wrong and then much
down on time and I don't even know where
spend all that time didn't feel like
that okay he's lining up yeah probably
trying to take on age 7 and then Bishop
h6 this kind of business
time morning anyway if I take any longer
here going to reduce on time I can
probably play Bishop f6 Bishop f6
intakes and 25 or something along these
lines maybe if it takes i should
actually just recapture yeah that's
actually the better defense this one
yeah it looks cute trying to take them
hmm hmm okay no time whatsoever but is
that winning maybe it is but check I
have my have my doubts
I've got some counter tag lined up there
with a three and so on so he has to
really kill me quickly otherwise it goes
the other way around hey three years a
thread what does this move that I don't
see it I a three or something now I just
take that yeah that's not threatening
anything I think Queen age 70 maybe
queen age seven I had to add to move
there anyway check check check check
check
how do i meet you Roxy three look see
two check check check check check check
mate yes we that was kind of close and
probably very lucky but anyway yeah that
was a tough tough game yay around here I
was thinking a black should be in great
shape but somehow I didn't it wasn't so
so great 97 mh4 I mean he's a tech is
rolling and I couldn't really i'm not so
quick here the computer gives me a
slight edge but with what exactly look a
to be eight no night 316 yeah i don't
know i tried this counter check against
the sea porn but well yeah and this
should lose the computer gives this as
winning so i was very lucky to survive
that i took this this is this is winning
for me well i mean it's a it's super
complicated and we didn't have much time
this seems to win for wine yeah i was
planning planning is this kind of thing
but Bishop g7 kills now
yeah no no black ass winning this this
was probably i did this win actually
chance this check this and this and I'm
dodging all those bullets here complete
win for black and threatening this also
and I mean everything is hanging okay he
did this I took it check chatia until
chastised torrance tons of material up
but of course he continued I mean I
don't think I did it particularly
quickly but it seemed to seem to win
check check he just gave over yeah check
and check all his pieces hoping to win
on time but I finally with the less than
a second on the clock I had this a one
mate okay whoa I was a tough game thanks
for watching